До виборів у німецький парламент – Бундестаг – залишився рівно місяць. У передвиборчій боротьбі
лідирує консервативний блок, який об’єднує Християнських демократів - партію Анґели Меркель – та Христиансько-соціальний союз.
Згідно з даними останнього опитування, за блок ХДС/ХСС готові проголосувати майже 40 відсотків виборців. Їхні суперники
– соціал-демократи – можуть розраховувати лише на двадцять чотири відсотки електорату. На третє місце вирвалися ліберали - за Вільну
демократичну партію Німеччини проголосують 10 відсотків виборців. За лівих - 8 відсотків, за "зелених" – 7 з половиною.
За "Альтернативу для Німеччини" - 7 відсотків електорату. Це вдвічі менше порівняно з 2015 роком,
коли на хвилі міграційної кризи рейтинг цієї партії сягнув 14-ти відсотків.
За даними інституту Forsa, Анґела Меркель і досі - найпопулярніший політик країни. Наприкінці березня, коли кандидатом на посаду канцлера від
соціал-демократів номінували Мартіна Шульца, про нього говорили як про сильного суперника Меркель. Вже у квітні рейтинги обох великий партій
практично зрівнялися. Проте згодом блок ХДС/ХСС вирвався вперед. Деякі аналітики вважають, що Мартін Шульц обрав невдалу тему для
передвиборчої кампанії – боротьбу за соціальну справедливість. Очевидно, виборців більше непокоять інші проблеми. Наприклад, 75 відсотків
німців виступають за якісну шкільну освіту та рівний доступ до неї. Також німецькі виборці занепокоєні
кримінальною ситуацією в країні та боротьбою з тероризмом. А от тема біженців хвилює їх усе менше.
Тож, найімовірніше, головна інтрига нинішніх парламентських виборів у Німеччині – не в тому, хто стане канцлером. Згідно з прогнозами,
Анґела Меркель, залишиться на четвертий термін. Питання в тому, з якою партією консерватори сформують правлячу коаліцію.
Непогані шанси, наприклад, у вільних демократів. Раніше вони вже входили до коаліції разом з ХДС/ХСС. Але 4 роки тому ліберали вперше
у своїй історії опинилися поза Бундестагом, не здолавши 5-відсотковий бар’єр. Нині ж опитування обіцяють їм повернення у німецький парламент.
Інший варіант - збереження нинішньої "великої" коаліції з консерваторів та соціал-демократів. Хоча, коли про це запитали Мартіна Шульца,
він заявив, що згоден на коаліцію з консерваторами, але тільки у ролі лідера.Деякі аналітики вважають,
що не варто категорично відкидати такий варіант. Адже за даними соціологів 46 відсотків німецьких
виборців досі не визначилися, за яку партію голосуватимуть 24 вересня.